well we just heard there from the
attorney general
just one officer has been charged they
were looking at
three officers and their involvement in
this case of briana taylor a 26 year old
emergency room technician who was killed
by police
we now know just one officer brett
hankinson has been
faces three charges of wanton
endangerment
now they were looking at a number of
options brianna taylor's family
had wanted to see manslaughter
in the second degree they knew that
murder was not
very likely because of self-defense laws
here which ruled that police
can shoot in self-defense brianna
taylor's
boyfriend fired the first shot he says
that is because
he mistook the police officers for
intruders and you can see here
to some of the people that have been
gathering here for the announcement this
has really been a focus of a lot of
intense protests
in emotion there is been a long delay in
trying to get progress with this case
which has frustrated a lot of people
it's
ignited a lot of emotion in america with
both politicians and
celebrities speaking out about the need
for justice
this result is one of the lesser charges
that they were looking at so i think we
can expect some frustration here amongst
the people
uh we can join uh now michelle pennings
she's one of the people that's been
gathering here
michelle please your reaction to today's
announcement
anger upset frustrated not
surprised we just believe that this is
what's always happened when it comes to
blacks in america
what did you want to see happen we
wanted to see all of the officers
brought up on charges and not
at the minimum which is one endangerment
but but real
neglect real murder charges what do you
think the impact will be
we know that louisville has been an
intense focus
of protest what's the fallout going to
be of this announcement
i hope the fallout is that we'll come
together and represent and we will show
through our voices we'll show through
our activism that this is not okay
that people who haven't had a heart will
start to have a heart and will
understand
that we are human but more importantly
we'll finally say you know what
here's 300 million dollars go take the
west end let that incorporate
secede from the city of louisville let
the black people have their own
community where they can do their own
thing
it's obvious they don't want us anymore
and we don't want to be someplace we're
not wanting
we know that the path to justice can be
painfully slow when it comes to
issues of police shootings in america
briana taylor's family
are to receive a settlement does that go
anyway do you think in in in satisfying
them or do you think this is a deeply
disappointing day for them
i'm sure it's disappointing for them
aaron andrews received 55 million
dollars for being peaked at by a white
man
in her bedroom briana taylor had her
life taken away
and received 12 million dollars it it's
never been about money money is just a
symbol of what
um we need to fight for and so no i
don't think that that compensates her or
the community for what was taken from us
they have been largely
peaceful protests here now this decision
has come down from the attorney general
what do you think we're going to see in
the hours and possibly days to come
god says that he blesses those that are
peace makers not peacekeepers this is
not a time
for keeping the peace this is a time for
making peace and the only way you can
make peace sometimes
is through chaos and the anger of people
so the truth can be exposed
so whatever needs to happen needs to
happen does that mean violence
it may mean but again as tamika mallory
said
what tamika mallory said at the
beginning of the protest with george
floyd america taught us how to be
violent
if there is violence it lays at their
feet michelle hennings thank you very
much for speaking to us will you
hear that strong feelings around this
some people speaking there
of burning down the city but at the
moment it is a calm atmosphere here i
think the news is still to be honest
trickling in here but just to remind you
again mark
the result from this attorney general
announcement just one officer of three
involved in the shooting of briana
taylor has been charged three charges
of wanton endangerment